hello thanks for coming
do you familiar okay or
sorry
maybe like this
yeah
uh okay so uh we're gonna talk about
front engineering addressing the
sensitivity of larger language models
first
foreign
I started out as a software engineer
been that for about 10 years
uh for the past five years I moved to
machine learning uh worked at a couple
of startups and uh kind of settled on on
mantis in LP
because they are great
um a bit about mantis
uh we are a remote NLP consultancy
the team is all over Europe
we
mantis was uh started a bit less than
two years ago
uh and since the Inception we valued the
open source and worked on medical and
reproducible data science
uh
it's been quite uh busy two years we
touched on most of the NLP tasks
um a little overview about what we're
gonna talk about
so we're going to look a bit about how
do you run and interact with large
language models
what is a prompt and how you construct
fronts
we're going to look a bit at our
experiment setup and then just we'll
look at the highlights of what we found
based on on those experiments
um
so large language models
or for those of you that aren't that
familiar with them you know
large language models are these
ginormous
models trained on uh very big data like
um
models that are multi-billion parameters
once you know it's pretty funny that the
whole of Wikipedia is now considered
quite a small data set compared to the
datasets that these models were trained
on
uh for example uh the smallest model
that we experimented with gptj 6 billion
model
uh uh comparison to that you know birth
is
3350 million uh and of course we have
the the one at the next uh at the other
end of the Spectrum gpt3 which is 175
billion
there are other bigger models but that's
where kind of where we settled
um important I mean another thing about
this large language models uh recently
they have been adopted quite a lot in uh
actually
uh working directly on NLP tasks so
because they are very big and they
become quite good at kind of everything
you know
um so people started using them to to
resolve this NLP tasks with just very
few examples uh we joke around the team
that you know pretty soon we'll have to
find other jobs because GPT 3D takes uh
takes over uh
so you know part through or not
[Music]
um
so how do we interact with these large
language models we used mostly these
three approaches
first one of course you you call some
apis and you know the the model is
provided by someone second
you either use some some kind of you
know hugging face accelerate for uh
helping you deal with uh with the model
or deep speed Mii more recently
um
regarding the apis for example these are
the ones that we used in in our
experiment uh open AI for uh the three
versions of GPT that we tested hacking
face inference you can host actually
quite a lot of models there but not so
much in the large models space not yet
at least they are quite they are working
on it quite quite actively
uh we use this for bloom uh a21 labs for
Jurassic 1 jumbo it's another very big
model uh cohere we tested the the
x-launch model and Goose AI I found it
for GPT neoix 20 billion
but you know the apis can be quite
expensive
especially if you want to like you want
a lot of uh requests for them so the
other approach you know is do something
like hacking face accelerate on your own
private infrastructure
in theory
you would only need like to load the
model you only need the code on the left
right but a bit of a running
accelerate and hacking phase integration
is under active development so it's
still there are still some a few kicks
to sort out most of these actually have
already been solved by the time of this
talk but you know I'm still highlighting
uh what the problem we had was so for
example
um
for opt models
for some reason you needed to load the
basic model part and the additional head
layer separately I couldn't really tell
you why
it's very important to to do that last
step you know with Thai weights because
that makes sure that everything will
stay in the same place and no funny
business is happening
and most of the time
um like accelerates automatically feels
the GPU memory right and then if if you
still have layers left from the big
model it fills the CPU and then even
more the disk and so on
um you want to make sure to leave some
space on the GPU it doesn't necessarily
make sure automatically you know so for
example if you have uh let's say more
than 500 tokens when you generate it's
usually a very good thing to manually
adjust to build the device map to leave
some space on on one of the gpus you
know because if not you'll you'll just
guess the OEM and
reloading the model takes quite a bit of
time
but this has actually been sorted quite
a bit recently like now you just have to
do this max memory thing and say for
each GPU hey use just this amount right
like for example in our case this is a
two GPU
instance with 24 gigabytes HBO and I
said you know let's live like six six
gigabytes leave for uh when you actually
call the generate function
um but no enough enough of that about
that uh let's actually focus on prompts
um
so what are prompts uh you use prompts
to interact with with the models right
The Prompt is the input given to the
generation function meant to guide the
model to generate the desired output
um the concept of prompt engineering
itself is relatively new uh but I've
seen it being like gaining popularity
quite a lot I think that is because when
you start playing with these large
language models you start realizing that
it kind of takes the place of future
engineering what we did before in future
engineering
uh part of this talk
is meant to show that yes it's really as
important as future engineering was
before
um so
how do you actually construct the fronts
usually follow some kind of schema
similar to this uh at first you need to
describe the task that you're trying to
solve right you see it in green
for example this example you see here is
the very simplest case we used in one of
the tasks we tested text classification
still just say let's find four labels
you know anger Joy optimism sadness it's
very good to have some kind of input
indicator in this case text
the input itself whatever it is you know
and output indicator again it's it's
good in general to keep them separate
and clean
but of course
most of the times uh you want zero shot
the problem right you'll give some
examples to the model so it can figure
out what you're actually trying to do
and shot being you know n the number of
examples you give uh and it's the same
uh the same thing right the Fourier for
each example you have the input
indicator the input outputs indicator
and in case of the examples of course
you also give it the the output itself
right
a couple of uh prompt construction
guidelines
uh uh make sure the description of the
task is pretty clear and uh not don't
use any you know fancy words as much as
possible
um if necessary include specifics but
gradually while testing
um
very important to have clear markers for
all the parts of the front right so make
sure to separate uh the task description
from the input and so on usually that
only means you know like some new lines
but in other cases you can get more
creative with you know new line plus
some vertical bars and so on just to
format a bit to let the model know hey
this is something you'll see over and
over again
uh this is a clearer separation of
things
and the quite important thing here is
the answer representation should be
quite diverse right what I mean by this
is
um let's say for the task classification
task
um
we give it three examples right so three
and shot uh it's not gonna help if all
the examples have the same output right
like for like before I give it three
examples all with the output sadness
for most models especially the smaller
ones you'll see that they kind of
think that hey this is a pattern I'll
always respond with sadness no matter
what you give me right
gpt3 and some other bigger models kind
of are smarter a bit but even they can
get uh can get messed up by by this
thing also like you know at the
beginning
here
let's say you you give examples but in
the order you gave them there you know
again like it might think that hey you
gave me these examples in the order here
now you'll probably want them in the
same order
so you have to think a bit about that
when you when you deal with the end
shots
also when you
um call the actual generation function
uh
either locally or on in in an API it's
still uh the same things apply
um I found you should be very careful of
the following things one trailing spaces
just remove them you know make sure
there is none because you won't know why
the output is just gibberish
um this marks tokens is quite important
I'll again use the the example of the
text classification
um
if you would use a big Max tokens uh
number like let's say 10 or 100 or
something
the model might understand that hey I
need to generate something else here
than just a label right
so in our case we used three for example
for text classification Y3 and not one
uh usually you know the first token that
it predicts is the space character
actually
then the other two
because uh for example sadness is two
tokens right not one sad and nest so you
have to think about that because if not
you won't understand why you know hey I
put Max tokens too I always get as
response sad and not sadness what's the
matter right
um
formatting of the labels matters make
sure the output that you expect is quite
uh clean and the words are quite uh you
know normal and easy for for the models
to understand
um and you know the the usual parameters
that you give the generation function
are also quite important topic okay and
temperature usually uh we rarely use uh
you know pretty the greedy approach
anymore
um
let's look a bit at the evaluation setup
so
we selected 12 large language models for
our experiment
um
you know Jurassic 1 jumbo Bloom GPT Da
Vinci coher the x large version the
biggest one they have
uh opt from Facebook the 30 billion
version and later the 13
20 billion Euro 2 from Google
another GPT smaller version you know
plenty five we just which just appeared
recently and uh you know another GPT 3
and GPT j6 billion these are ordered by
size right keep in mind this because the
next graphs you'll see will also have
the models ordered by size
um
so for each of those models we settled
on uh five and five of the most common
NLP tasks you know text classification
named entity recognition similarity QA
and summarization I would point out that
we tried to select some data sets for
them that weren't the simplest ones you
know we wanted to give the models a bit
of a challenge
wasn't the case for every data set but
yeah
um
and so for each task we constructed five
prompts we did it kind of empirically
trying for each prompt to raise its
quality and complexity
um depending on tasks we used
multiple shots for the classification we
used 135 and 10 shot near similarity in
QA one three and five and uh
summarization only zero and one because
of a length constraint
an important asterisk to to mention here
is uh we only tested on
[Music]
quite a small sample of from each data
set 100 that's mostly because of cost
constraints it's very expensive to
experiment with all of these
combinations I would mention though that
we did test like 450 100 to 200 300 and
so that the score kind of settles at 100
so we selected that as a as the basis
uh right so next we'll look at some
takeaways based on the experiments we
did what we found from them uh the
biggest one and the one that I actually
the care that you remember the most is
from quality actually matters
[Music]
um
we have here a graph showing just a few
models uh for each model we have the
different prompts ordered by kind of
their complexity we can see that not
necessarily more complex means the
better always
you know but I think the main takeaway
here is that uh
the difference in in some of these cases
is two x even 3x better score right
so that's that's pretty amazing and that
should show the value of uh of front
engineering just just there right
um if that isn't enough to convince you
um maybe this this will
um
with the right prompts we actually
managed to beat
a very big model with like Jupiter
DaVinci is one of the biggest models we
tested on and the gptj is the smallest
one right and with the right prompt uh
it managed to surpass the results from
gpt3 again you know that 100 sample is
something to keep in mind but uh
uh still pretty amazing uh
the error bar that you see there is
basically the difference between the
front and the prompt scores so of course
gpt3 was uh you know more stable and you
saw how how big the difference was for
the smaller models
uh next next takeaway point is uh
complex prompts are a double-edged sword
what do I mean by that
um we tested
um
for all models we tested the difference
between
let's see our series of simple prompts
kind of simple prompts versus
much more complex prompts uh what we
found
is that you know
only 25 and gpt3 at the beginning
weren't affected by it gpt3 actually it
helped a lot
for all the other models it wasn't
really the case bloom again like you
know it's it's a big model so you would
expect it not to be
confused too much and when when I say
complex complex prompts I mean that uh
is instead of what you saw at the
beginning these have like uh very big
descriptions for the input indicator for
the output indicator you know uh a lot
more uh characters maybe for uh the
separation between them so things that
should let the model know hey this is
the very clear
prompt structure right but in most cases
because
the other models were smaller it seems
you know it they just don't manage to
understand that and it actually messes
with them
um
I mean this is pretty amazing we'll talk
about it so
very soon
um
another thing
more and shots don't always equal better
performance this is quite an interesting
find uh
so always is really important to keep in
mind there
theoretically they should right but
again what we found was this this is a
distribution of the end shots that
generated best results for uh for one of
the tasks
uh and basically what you see here is
that for some adults uh five three or
even one end shot did that did better
than uh 10 and shots
right again maybe this is because uh
some smaller models uh get confused if
you give too much to them at once right
uh I can say that for example gpd3 did
okay with 10 shots
um
this is uh graph showing the performance
variability by n-shot
so we can see that for some adults it's
very big difference between right like a
one shot and 10 shots for some others
like uh 25 or gpt3
doesn't make that much difference of
course when when you want the best
results you will you will try to give
him as as much insurance as possible but
you know just saying be careful with it
test a bit more depending on the model
um
so instruction fine-tune models shine a
lot
um
we we're really happy that we got to
test 25 XXL which came out just about
two weeks ago uh and fall down this
amazing results like um
it's actually did better than gpt3 uh
and I want to
mention here that in one of the tasks in
the name entity recognition task it did
really poorly so that actually affected
the main score you know dragged it down
because if not it would have been even
uh even uh even more amazing uh that
just means basically that you know it
should be instructional fine tuned on
more and near tasks uh but again like
this is more amazing when you think
about the fact that 25 is 15 times
smaller than gpt3 you can actually Host
this model on a 2 GPU instance
uh this is just a graph that shows uh
kind of the overall performance of all
the models in our in our tests
um
with a small Mission we forgot to add
the gptj here at the at the end but it
kind of performed as good as
or here I would say so pretty good for
for the smallest model
um
oh yeah and uh
basically what I wanted to show to this
was
um again the power of prompt engineering
because if we would have only used the
simplest prompts
this graph would look like what you see
with the red lines right so if the
performance would have went down quite a
lot even for the bigger models
so why do we bother with all of these
things like why do we care so much well
it kind of all comes down to cost right
um big models can be very expensive to
query usually 10 times on even more than
uh than smaller models and when you have
big data sets you know you do a lot of
queries
that kind of uh can get very very
expensive so you might think hey maybe I
should host a smaller model on a private
infrastructure
write some examples of this are the the
GPT ga1 which is can basically go in one
GPU with a bit of a hug you face
accelerator playing or 25.
um for example in our experiments we
estimate that we queried around 5
million tokens per model
um
and if you're interested in what that
adds up to
um
you can see here like half of the cost
goes basically to half of the models we
tested which went in
AWS infrastructure but I would mention
here that that cost the AWS one uh
maybe if you work a bit more on each
model and what the actual uh
requirements are for it it would go down
quite a lot because for example you
don't need the 4 GPU machine to run gptj
but we kind of forgot and run it with
that you know so the cost reflects that
whereas the the API costs I kind of
fixed those are it
maybe only for you know open AI decides
to lower their cost again or something
um right so
some final thoughts
um in terms of future work
it's quite interesting actually because
when we started working on this
experiment about two months ago
instruction-based fine-tuning and set
fit which I'll talk about really quickly
weren't present that much and we said
okay yeah a few prompt engineering is
really like to the Future Powerhouse and
everything like that right
uh we still plan to experiment with uh
with front and front engineering but uh
it's clear that we have to combine it
somehow with the instruction based fine
tuning we clearly saw that it won a lot
by the way like uh some of the other
models
were a bit instruction based pontoon
like gbt3 was a bit instruction-based
fine tune the gpdj also but with not
with the same techniques and the same
amount of instructions as 25.
um
and I want to mention set feeds maybe
some of you heard of it it's a technique
that came out recently it kind of allows
you not to play with large language
models necessarily but instead play with
a small transformer and just use a few
examples
and uh get like really good results in
some cases it is a bit the large
language Model results
um
we plan to
write
quite more in depth about the results we
got
so follow us on on medium follow the
blogs
if you're interested in seeing the exact
blogs results and and the code that we
used to to experiment this is the
experiment repository on GitHub
um
for all other things NLP related uh
follow us on Twitter
and I would like in closing I would like
to reiterate the takeaway points you
know front quality matters
complex prawns can be a double-edged
sword
more end shots don't always don't always
equal better performance
um instruction fine-tune models shined a
lot
um uh and yeah I mean considering all
that it does affect cost greatly
uh thank you and if you have questions
[Applause]
thank you Daniel do we have any
questions that one I'll come over with
the mic
let's start with you
thank you for the talk I was wondering
if you could give us some more detail on
what constitutes a complex prompt and
whatnot right uh I actually have some
some examples in the appendix
so for example this is the first prompt
in the text classification as you can
see it's quite simple
this is an example of a more complex
prompt
um
I I had to split it in two columns but
it's the same thing it is the same
prompt like for example you see that
um
first at the top it just puts the input
then all of this basically is the the
test description which as we can see
it's quite bigger you know it uses all
all these
additional
characters and so on and it does that
for all uh n shots like it doesn't just
keep the latest description at the
beginning you know it does it for all
the answers
so you can see like the difference in
complexity between this and
um you know this
or even
or even this which
was the the most complex one of our
fronts which I would say it's pretty
simple compared to compared to this
all right other questions
oh and uh really quick besides that
sorry I forgot to mention like uh
there's this really big repository of
hundreds of prompts called prompt Source
the complex prompts come come from uh
from front source
things first of all really great talk
um I had a question on this uh what you
mentioned a couple of times instruction
based fine tuning yeah if you could
elaborate a bit on it
oh it's a
I mean
uh just in summary really quick
it means that after the the model was
trained as all the other generation
models were trained you know with uh
just with masks to fine-tuning and two
Mass training and things like that
um they actually took a lot of uh
prompts basically that's what the
instruction part refers to
um and trained trained the model to give
the correctors on the results based on
those fronts right uh that's why uh you
see
let me get to it really quick you see
this thing here with 25 right it doesn't
matter it I mean there is a small
difference but you can see it here but
it basically didn't matter what prompt
you give gave it because it was already
uh it already saw a lot of fronts for
that uh that type of uh problem right
if you get a question over here
all right thanks for the talk
um
is it seems like you've worked a lot
with several different kinds of language
models and uh the prompts that you've
had them have been
like consistent across these models yeah
uh do you think that uh different kinds
of models will have uh different
reactions to different styles of prompts
because for example like stable
diffusion it's like it's sort of its own
thing with like the image generation but
uh it's grown a lot and you see that
like very very complex prompts have much
much better results for that yeah uh so
I would say first of all
um there's quite a bit of difference
between the natural language uh models
and the prompts you give them and the
visual uh models they still I mean for
the visual models they still go through
a kind of a natural language model at
first and then uh that gets transferred
to to the visual one but
the what you want from it is greatly
differs right for for the natural
language one you mostly wanted to
understand what you're telling it to do
and kind of uh make little uh logic
assumptions right
so for example you saw that in gpt3 you
can give it uh what's one plus one and
it will know that it's two right things
like that so it makes quite small
connections I would say that's kind of
the difference between the two
and yes I mean
it really greatly depends like I said
you can see here you know the difference
between the complex and simple ones it
really depends on the model
uh
I would say you know
decide on which model you want to play
with and then
try different levels of complexity
uh yeah I I don't know if I can answer
that better
quite a lot I would say uh I mean you
start seeing a lot of similarities
between them uh it's just that you know
uh depending on the data sets they were
trained with and uh all the instructions
they they've seen up until now
uh the the response will be different
uh hi uh so my question is like if if we
use more than just a single sentence
like if there's a big paragraph
and we are trying to classify whether uh
whether this okay we have like 10
sentences and if it is about data
science yes or no you think this could
work and especially with the limitation
of the maximum token yeah yeah so that
that's uh I mean first of all great
question uh that's a it really depends
on the model
um
for example in the summarization task
actually can show you the results for it
um
the bigger the model kind of the better
it did just because you know it was able
to understand that lengthy prompt better
um
the the length limitation is very real
indeed like that's why first
memorization for example we only limited
to examples that had 500 tokens so that
we can actually give it also an example
before that you know
um
I would say in this case
the the size of the matter does does
matter quite a lot
um because uh like I I had cases in the
past where um
I was able to give gpt3 the big version
of version I was able to to give it uh
like you said you know a big example
with hey do this for the for all 10
sentences at once right and it actually
did uh I would say most of these models
up until you know here wouldn't be able
to do that at the same time for for
multiple inputs right so that's another
thing you can actually have multiple
inputs with bigger models right like you
could say uh
classify the the following texts in to
these four labels maybe give one two
shots to these examples
then you know
have multiple inputs like one two three
four and then you know just expect from
it to give the responses for all of them
in the big models cases it usually works
from my experience from what I saw it
really messes up the the smaller models
I think it's mostly the size
unfortunately yeah I mean we all would
like to think that you know you can do
some uh some
very uh you know uh
cool training to to make the smaller
model better and we saw that kind of you
can with flan T5 right with the
instruction fine tuning but up to a
certain point like unfortunately after
you know uh adding more complexity to it
means
you know it will just have uh
limitations
uh we have time for one more question
have you looked at any language models
that combine
um pre-training on knowledge graphs
not really I would like to but uh not
really sorry
if you have more questions you can ask
Daniel uh during our Shuffle time but
otherwise
yeah we'll get our next session started
in five minutes income
[Applause]